Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das kann sich weder entscheiden.
Ja. Okay.
So Leute.
Erster Arbeitstag rum.
Und wie war's bei Euch?
Ich weiß, dass einige bei Euch auch heute
ersten Tag hatten.
Also.
Urlaub.
Also, was ich bei mir sagen kann ist,
es ist...
Ähm, was ich sagen kann...
Ich wurde gerade ein bisschen abgelenkt vom zweiten Bildschirm.
Es...
Es ist Abkürzungs-Overload, Leute.
Es ist... Die haben ja... Okay.
Der alte Laden, wo ich gewesen bin,
der hatte ja schon viele Abkürzungen, ja?
Und...
Die übertreiben es richtig.
Die übertreiben es komplett.
Da ist jedes zweite Wort irgendeine Abkürzung.
Und da noch irgendeine interne Abkürzung.
Ich gucke gerade in meine E-Mails.
Ich habe heute noch gar nicht in die E-Mails reingeguckt.
Sind wieder sehr weird champige Dinger am Start.
Eine Frage, wer da wieder rum spammt.
Wisst ihr, was ein Monats-Ticket mittlerweile kostet?
Die sind wirklich nicht mehr ganz dicht.
Ich habe geguckt,
ein Monats-Ticket von mir zur Arbeit kostet
175 Euro.
Und es ist nicht weit.
Und das ist nur...
Also, eine kurze Strecke.
Mit 49 Euro Ticket ist das halbwegs erschwinglich
und irgendwie auch wieder lohnenswert.
Aber 175 Euro.
Ich meine, du kannst dafür theoretisch fast Auto fahren.
Wenn du wirklich nur diese Strecke fährst...
Ich meine, insgesamt kostet das Auto im Monat natürlich mehr.
Aber wenn du wirklich nur diese Strecke...
Also auch mit tanken und sowas.
Ich meine, ich habe ja eh ein Elektroauto.
Da sieht es wieder anders aus.
Also wahrscheinlich ist es billiger,
tatsächlich mit dem Auto zu fahren.
Gut, wenn du wahrscheinlich alles einrechnest,
so von Abnutzung bis vielleicht...
Aber selbst dann, das ist schon ordentlich.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Ihr habt da ein riesiges Confluence,
nur für die Abkürzung.
Ja gut, sowas nennt man ja auch Glossar.
Das ist ja schon ganz sinnvoll.
Ob man jetzt nur ein eigenes Confluence dafür braucht...
Ja, also ich bin...
Ich bin aufgestanden heute so kurz nach sieben.
Und ich war um...
Ja, ich würde sagen so um 17 Uhr ungefähr war ich wieder daheim.
Also 10 Stunden von Aufstehen bis Heimkommen.
Das geht eigentlich durchaus, ja.
Aber...
Da sieht man wieder, wie nice Homeoffice ist.
Und...
Ich musste halt heute auch erstmal gucken,
dass alles funktioniert, ja.
Von Notebook bis Teamszugang
und Remote-Möglichkeiten und sowas.
Im Detail kann ich es euch natürlich nicht erzählen.
Aber es ist halt immer ein größerer Aktivismus.
Also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
wäre es ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit gewesen,
dass ich dort anfange
und am gleichen Tag noch
einen funktionierenden Account,
Notebook, Handy und Login und alles habe.
Ich meine, okay, alles wird beim neuen auch noch nicht gehen.
Aber...
Also muss ich sagen, es ist Hut ab.
Das ist, äh...
Ja, es ist...
Hut ab, das ist, äh...
Nicht verkehrt, ja.
Schon nicht schlecht.
Schon nicht schlecht, dass sie das alles so hingekriegt haben.
Kann man, denke ich, nichts sagen.
Also das habe ich schon deutlich schlimmer gesehen.
Erstmal Twitch, ja.
Erstmal die Leuten Kekl beibringen.
MonkaS.
Kekwade.
Wirst du Homeoffice machen können?
Ja, das ist ja...
Übrigens, mein Chef heißt auch Daniel mit Vornamen.
Ganz lustig gerade, dass du im Chat bist.
Ähm...
Wirst du Homeoffice machen können? Ja.
Aktuell ist es einmal die Woche,
wo ich nach Frankfurt muss.
Aber so perspektivisch
ist es wahrscheinlich einmal alle 14 Tage.
Ist das dein Chef?
Glaube ich nicht, wäre ein ganz schön großer Zufall.
Wie agil seid ihr?
Also was ich bis jetzt mitbekommen habe, ist,
dass der gesamte Laden...
Ich meine, das ist ein riesen, riesen Finanzdienstleister
mit tausenden Mitarbeitern oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele die insgesamt haben.
Die sind nicht sonderlich agil.
Es gibt so ein paar Projekte, wo sie...
Also was ich heute am ersten Tag so mitbekommen habe,
ist, dass es so viele Leute gibt.
Es gibt so ein paar Projekte, wo sie...
Also was ich heute am ersten Tag so mitbekommen habe,
Es gibt natürlich ein paar Projekte, wo sie sagen,
sie sind super agil.
Aber wenn ich dann schon mitbekomme,
dass es statische
kubernetes
Environments gibt,
die von Hand gepflegt werden,
teilweise.
Was heißt von Hand?
So händisch immer angepasst werden.
Also es ist schon
ein bisschen
oldschool.
Aber das finde ich gar nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, gerade Finanzdienstleister
haben ja auch gewisse Auflagen.
Das macht, denke ich,
schon Sinn.
Und der große Vorteil bei denen versus
meinem alten Arbeitgeber, was ich bis jetzt sehe,
ist, die sind nicht einfach nur
sagen wir mal so,
so elefantenmäßig unterwegs,
sondern wenigstens auch gründlich.
Also da weiß
man auch wirklich jeder an jeder
Stelle, ist immer ein bisschen übertrieben, aber
an den meisten Stellen,
wie jetzt der Ablauf sein muss.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Nicht so dieses theoretisch, die wissen was,
aber wir halten uns nicht dran.
Ich glaube, die nehmen das schon wirklich
ernst.
Ja.
Hast du nicht mehr montags frei?
Doch, habe ich.
Und wisst ihr, was ich auch sehr nett
fand, oder sehr
mitgedacht?
Ich habe heute
meinen Chef gefragt, wie ist denn das,
ich bin ja montags da, normalerweise bin ich ja montags
nicht da, ausnahmsweise.
Dann bleibe ich einfach Freitag daheim.
Dann meinte er, ne, ne, bleib mal Donnerstag daheim,
Freitag ist doch Feiertag.
Okay, habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Der alte Laden
hätte bestimmt nichts gesagt,
in der Hoffnung, ich kriege es nicht mit.
Also,
insofern, bis jetzt,
also die haben wirklich einen guten Eindruck gemacht.
Auch
der eine, der da war,
der mir ein bisschen
die Sachen gezeigt hat, der hat sich auch Mühe gegeben,
die haben im Vorfeld extra so einen
so einen, ne nicht Floucher,
so eine Mindmap erstellt, mit Dingern,
aber ich meine, ich habe am ersten Tag null
durchgeblickt, so 30
Milliarden Abkürzungen, das Einzige, was ich
teilweise verstanden habe, ist, wenn sie was von Google Cloud
und Terraform und sowas erzählt haben,
ansonsten habe ich nicht wirklich viel
verstanden.
Wir haben zweimal Max im Team,
mich und noch
einen anderen.
Müssen wir uns mal gucken, wie wir das jetzt, wie wir uns
jetzt verständigen, wer wann, wie, wo
gemeint ist.
Ist das wieder eine Bank?
Ja,
nicht direkt, aber
geht in die Richtung, ja so 100%
nicht, weil ansonsten kann man sich so sehr,
kann man sich relativ
zu
sehr einschränken.
Woblos
auf der Nase, ja.
Woblos, da
würde ich mal gucken, Alter.
Wenn die Leute im Meeting sagen,
Woblos, was sagst du so?
Was sagst du
hier dazu? Kann man den
Link aufmachen, ohne dass man
sich irgendwas einfällt?
Dass man sich irgendwas einfängt.
Was sagst du hierzu?
Screenshot verstehe ich nicht.
Nein,
es wurde nur alles an Zugängen,
haben wir ausprobiert.
Ich habe mich angemeldet,
und ich glaube auch,
bis ich richtig an irgendwelchen
Live-Systemen was sinnvoll machen kann,
wird wahrscheinlich auch noch der ein oder
andere Tag vergehen.
Für mich heißen die Systeme einfach nur
alle furchtbar kryptisch zur Zeit.
Hast du mal Zeit darauf,
hast du mal darauf reagiert,
ich kann nicht mehr lesen, Leute.
Kannst du mal darauf reagieren, er redet darüber,
dass die Arbeit bei der Arbeit
besser ist als Homeoffice.
Ach, er schon wieder.
Redet er darüber, oder redet der Blogartikel
darüber? Ich meine, wir können jetzt
ja schlecht reacten
auf die Blog-Reacting-Reaction.
Wobei, warum eigentlich nicht?
Das ist, dass wir die ganzen großen Reaction-Channels
auch ihren Content produzieren die ganze Zeit.
Nico, danke schön für den Sub.
Ach ja, die Frage kam doch eben irgendwo,
ob ich schon Arched auf dem Notebook installiert hätte,
gell? Irgendwo, wo war das denn?
Arched?
Hier, und schon Arched
auf dem Notebook installiert?
Nee, und jetzt
kommt der Hammer.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie sie das
machen wollen auf Dauer.
Also, beziehungsweise, sie machen das ja schon
auf Dauer, aber
wie lange ich das aushalte,
ohne zu meckern?
Und zwar, ich hab natürlich erst mal
einen Windows-Notebook in die Hand getriffen,
und ich hab mir gedacht,
ich lass mal einen Windows-Notebook in die Hand
gedrückt bekommen.
Was auch sonst, ja.
Das alleine wäre noch nicht so schlimm gewesen,
aber, jetzt haltet euch mal fest,
es gibt auf diesem Windows-Notebook
nicht mal WSL,
und auch kein neues Terminal,
nicht mal Visual Studio Code.
Okay, das kann man sich
nachinstallieren lassen.
Das kann man sich nachinstallieren lassen.
Nee, nee, es ist,
ich glaub, es ist Windows 10.
Nicht mal WSL, ja.
Dafür gibt es wohl
irgendwo Putty.
Putty, Alter.
Putty,
und man kann,
man kann,
sich irgendwo
in Azure eine
Linux-VM aufsetzen lassen,
wo man sich dann per Putty
drauf connecten, oder per Mobile X-Term
drauf connecten kann, und die kann man
sich dann einrichten, wie man will.
Vor allem, es ist eine RedHat-VM.
Weil RedHat
auch so ein geiles
Arbeitsbetriebssystem ist.
RedHat.
Ich hab jetzt eine VM angelegt mit RedHat 9
drauf.
Also,
ich glaube, da werde ich in Zukunft
ein bisschen meckern müssen, weil es so eine gescheite
Arbeitsumgebung hat. Also,
ich werde erst mal West Term auf das Notebook drauf machen.
Das braucht, glaube ich, keine
Installation.
Warte mal, für Windows?
Ist das das?
Das ist ein Zip.
Ich meine, ich habe es noch nie unter
Windows benutzt,
aber das kann man anscheinend auch
ohne Installation benutzen.
Das ist das Erste, was ich mir auf jeden Fall
schon mal draufhauen werde.
Das ist das Erste, was ich mir auf jeden Fall schon mal
draufhauen werde.
Eine Runde West Term.
Habe ich übrigens noch nie unter Windows gestartet.
Wie sieht das jetzt aus?
West Term GUI.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Da ist es.
Ja, das kann man wenigstens halbwegs gescheit
verwenden.
Okay,
standardmäßig sieht das äußerst
cringe aus.
Aber immerhin.
Immerhin ein halbwegs gescheites
Terminal.
Da muss man jetzt halt die Fallshell
und alles noch anpassen, aber es passt schon.
Schau mal, deine Config importieren kannst.
Ne, da fehlt mir allein schon die
Schriftart und sowas.
Werde ich dann, werde ich, werde ich,
werde ich, werde ich, werde ich,
werde ich machen.
Mal gucken, wo das die Config
... Das werde ich morgen ausprobieren.
Auf dem Arbeitsnotebook.
Tja, weil die erst, weil die keinen
Linux Notebooks haben.
Ich werde ihnen schon in nächster Zeit
auf den Keks gehen, weil es ist unglaublich
nervig ohne gescheites
Terminal.
Selbst mit WSL konnte man nicht alles
gescheit machen.
Man braucht ja vielleicht auch mal
irgendein UI-Programm und sei es
so ein Wireshark, um irgendwas
zu dumpen oder so.
Oder sei es, dass ich Kubernetes mäßig mal was
ausprobieren will und Minikube starten mit
Docker, mach das mal unter Windows.
Das geht ja überhaupt nicht.
Ähm, pff, nee.
Mal gucken,
ob ich mich irgendwie über das Arbeitsnotebook
kundeln kann dann.
Von der Linux-VM daheim.
Mal gucken, ob das erlaubt ist.
Nee.
Das geht nicht.
Weil ich keine Admin-Rechte
hab, was zu installieren.
Nur weil was theoretisch
lauffähig wäre unter Windows,
heißt ja nicht, dass es auch
lauffähig ist
unter den aktuellen Gegebenheiten.
Senior Linux Engineer
unter Linux. Ich hab schon gesehen,
es gibt dort auch Tage,
die einfach von 9 bis
16.30 Uhr
Meeting dauerhaft sind.
Ja.
Senior Meeting Engineer.
Pogger Subscription.
Der Firmen-Laptop,
Leute, das hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Das Ding wurde installiert
und ungelogen.
Wusstet ihr, dass man das hier ausblenden kann?
Wusstet ihr, dass es ein Setting gibt,
dass das hier unendlich lang sein kann?
Die gesamte, ohne Scheiß,
das hab ich noch nie gesehen,
die gesamte, aber ohne Mist,
Leute, die gesamte
Taskleiste ist voll mit Icons.
Die haben da 18
verschiedene Security-Tools drauf
installiert.
Aber gut,
das muss alles highly secure
sein.
Ja, wenn man Linux-Präsenten
verwenden würde, bräuchte man es wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Oh, das ist lahm
teilweise. Oh Mann.
Ne, das
Microsoft Video hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ja, geht mir
im Prinzip auch so.
Ne, CPU-Auslastung
ist gar nicht so hoch, aber sobald du
was Neues aufmachst,
leckt es erstmal rum, weil 30.000
Virenscanner was scannen müssen.
Ne, ich hab eigentlich
jetzt schon mehr oder weniger alles gesagt.
Es war ein riesen
Aus,
nicht aus, ein riesen
Anzahl
an Abkürzungen
am ersten Tag. Es bestand
alles nur aus Abkürzungen.
Alles hatte Abkürzungen.
Und nachdem das auch oftmals sehr kurze
Abkürzungen sind, fühlt mich nicht
wundern, wenn die Abkürzungen auch
doppelt
belegt werden.
Waren sie zufrieden? Das weiß
ich nicht. Ich hab ja noch nichts gemacht.
Die absurdeste
Abkürzung weiß ich nicht.
Ne, absurd waren die
eigentlich nicht.
Die haben schon Sinn gemacht.
Aber es waren halt viele.
Und im Detail kann ich euch
ja nicht die Abkürzungen erzählen,
beziehungsweise was dahinter steckt.
Liegt das irgendwas?
Gab's CacW als Abkürzung? Ne, das hab ich noch
nicht gesehen. Aber da bin ich dafür,
das als ersten Service einzuführen.
CacW, der CacW-Service.
Also nein, das hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Ich kann ja auch kein Arch benutzen zur Zeit,
weil ich ein Windows-Notebook hab.
So, morgen Home Office, dann
richte ich das mal alles ein bisschen schöner ein.
Und sodass man
halbwegs alles verwenden kann.
Ja, das ist
ich glaube, das ist noch
Windows 10 gewesen.
Ja, wenn ich das richtig, richtig
im Blick hab.
Ne, da kannst du nix selbst drauf
installieren. Hab mir ein Recht zu geben, ja ist klar.
Das frage ich mich auch, ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich hab heute bei einem Kollege gesehen,
dass der irgendwie
MOBAX-Term offen hatte mit 100
Tabs. Wobei ich Anfälle bekomme,
wenn ich produktiv mit
MOBAX-Term arbeiten muss.
Wenn man ein gescheites, lagfreies Terminal
gewöhnt ist.
Ne, ne, ich kann da nicht einfach.
Leute, ich kann nicht einfach über USB
was nachinstallieren.
Ich brauche ja die Windows-Sachen, ja.
Zum Einloggen, zum Anmelden,
zum dran teilnehmen, zum reingucken.
Es ist nicht so, dass es unsinnig ist,
dass da Windows drauf ist.
Ich persönlich fände es sehr nice, wenn man
vielleicht noch ein zweites Notebook bekommen würde,
zum Linux-Draufbauen.
Also, ich kann da nicht einfach
über USB was nachinstallieren.
noch ein zweites Notebook bekommen würde,
zum Linux-Draufmachen.
Ich werde das vielleicht mal anregen in Zukunft.
Ich könnte mir halt vorstellen,
dass sie da sehr pingelig sind.
Red Hat mag auf dem
Server gut sein, als
Arbeitssystem ist es
nix.
Sollte ich vielleicht machen.
Ich kann aus religiösen Gründen
nicht mit Windows arbeiten.
Warum nicht?
Also, Windows kann ich ja
verstehen, aber Azure
und Google Cloud sind doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Was war das für ein ZIP-Programm?
Das war pzip.
Tabi.sh
Das ist nur Windows oder
Das ist nur Windows oder wie?
44,5
Alter, was ist denn da los?
Ist das Windows
Only? Ah, hier.
SSH und Serial Client
für Windows. Das sieht gar nicht,
das klingt gar nicht so übel. Braucht das
Admin-Rechte?
Der Rechner ist gut.
Das Notebook ist gut, was ich bekommen habe.
32 GB RAM und
ein i7
13000 irgend etwas.
Mobile
i7 oder i5
Das Notebook ist wirklich
sehr potent.
Gibt es hier auch nicht
Prereleases, Leute?
Was normales vielleicht?
Nee, irgendein
HP-Notebook?
Gib nur Alpha-Software hier.
Portable, das brauche ich.
Portable x64
Okay, das
hört sich auch nicht so schlecht an.
Oh nee, das ist das falsche.
Wo war ich jetzt?
Leute, ich klicke nochmal durch.
Downloads?
Hier.
Nee, leider kein
Thinkpad.
Aber ohne Mist, unter Windows
laufen die eigentlich alle ganz gut.
Moment, ist das ein
Elektron? Ist das
Browser-basiertes Terminal? Sehe ich das hier richtig?
Okay, erstmal 800 MB RAM
weg beim Start.
Machen wir das doch mal.
Warte mal, ich mach das mal kurz auf. Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
Leute,
ich hab ne PCI-Express-SSD
mit
5000 MB die Sekunde
sequenziell und...
Rename? Das hier ist doch
Tabby.
Boah, da krieg ich ja...
Ich dreh ja schon am Rad, wenn ich das sehe.
Enable Analytics?
Nein. Enable Global
Hotkey? Nein.
Vielleicht.
Jetzt hier erstmal nicht.
Language? English? UK?
Nee. US?
Kona?
Ja.
Okay.
Jetzt bräuchte ich nur noch irgendeine ZSH oder so.
Aber von da
kann man sich ja
dann wenigstens auf irgendeine
andere VM verbinden.
Gut, es
wird schon passen.
Ich denk, das geht schon.
Senior
Meeting
Champion.
Ja, ich stream schon
ne ganze Weile.
Halt
meistens keinerlei Gaming-Geschichten.
Wenn du bei mir mal guckst
in der Streaming-History.
Da wirst du feststellen.
Mensch, Twitch,
kriegt mal eure Domains auf die Reihe.
Max, Klappe.
Ja, wenn du dir die History anguckst,
was wir so gemacht haben.
Arch-Linux-Packages
gebaut.
Github-Actions uns angeguckt.
TrueNAScale.
Ja.
Angeguckt, TrueNAScale.
C-Sharp programmiert. Das hat ja nichts
mit Youtube-Content zu tun.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ach, ich werd das schon irgendwie auf die
Reihe kriegen.
Jasper,
danke für den Sub.
Wie gesagt,
das hab ich nicht gesehen.
Bist du als Streamer erkannt?
Nein.
Quatsch.
So bekannt ist mein Twitch-Stream
jetzt auch nicht.
Youtube kennen vielleicht die ein oder anderen.
Aber Twitch guckt doch im Vergleich zu
vielen anderen Leuten auf Twitch.
Sind ja hier nicht viele Leute.
Ich hab im Durchschnitt so was
zwischen
230 oder so Zuschauer.
Irgendwie im Schnitt
220, 230 oder so.
Ey, aber man muss sagen, ich finde für
Technik-Streams und das, was wir machen,
ist das gar nicht schlecht.
Ist schon...
Wirklich okay.
Aber im Vergleich
zu großen Gaming-Streams auf Twitch ist es
natürlich gar nichts.
Wie viele...
Weiß das jemand von euch?
Wie viele Zuschauer hat Ninja
eigentlich aktuell noch?
Das war ja mal vor...
so 3, 4 Jahren.
Ist ja schon eine ganze Weile her.
Das war noch vor Corona.
Der größte Streamer
ever.
Ich meine, er wird mehr als
3 Zuschauer haben aktuell.
Aber wahrscheinlich immer noch ziemlich viele.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr in den Sphären
wie der Fortnite-Hype so
mega groß war.
Gibt es
kostenloses Wasser und Obst?
Nee, weder das eine noch das andere.
Bei uns
gibt es
Keck-Kundeneinwilligungserklärung.
Ah, das finde ich cool.
Könnte man da nicht noch irgendwie
Kundenerklärung,
Einwilligung oder so rausmachen?
Weil dann könnte man das wirklich wegen dem W
Keck-W nennen.
Ähm...
Spieler zahlen bei Battlefield...
Hey, die sind
für Battlefield 2042
Verhältnisse...
Die sind glaube ich gar nicht so mies.
Ja.
Also für Battlefield-Verhältnisse
sind die gar nicht so mies.
Die waren schon schlechter.
Ich verstehe zwar nicht, wie das einer wirklich am Stück
spielen kann, aber...
Okay.
Und jetzt muss ich mal gucken.
New World.
Steam-Stats.
Oh, das ist wirklich
schlecht, Alter.
Also ich glaube,
das habe ich auch bei einem MMO noch nicht gesehen.
Dass die
angefangen hat mit einer Million
und
innerhalb quasi
von einem Jahr...
Hier haben sie
hier haben sie ja die
neuen Server gestartet. Neue Server ziehen immer neue Leute an.
Ah, deswegen klappt mir das
auch so gut. Gerade bei
Games Deep Path of Exile und sowas.
Ah, das ist krass. Guck mal, die haben es geschafft
innerhalb von einem halben Jahr.
In einem halben Jahr, man.
Runter
von einer Million auf
22.000.
Boah, das ist
echt...
Diesen krassen
Abfall habe ich ja noch nirgendwo gesehen.
Wurdest du auf der Arbeitsschau gefragt, wie du C++
findest? Ne.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich in nächster Zeit
gefragt werde. Du, Max, was sagst du
zu C++?
Nö. Die haben alle einen Winner aus
Notebook. Alle.
Also Linux Admins.
Ja, aber die haben alle einen Winner aus Notebook.
Das widerspricht sich vielleicht ein bisschen, aber ja.
Ist halt so.
Ja, bestimmt.
Ist schon...
Ist immer irgendwie so.
Gerade wenn du bei dem neuen Zeug
noch nicht so richtig drinnen bist.
Aber...
Ne, wirklich.
Also das einzige,
was man ja da vermisst, ist nicht die alte Firma.
Sondern, dass man
sich dort an alles gewöhnt hatte.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich das, was man
vermisst. Die alte Firma wird man nicht wirklich
vermissen, weil die ist ja auch der Grund, warum man
überhaupt abgehauen ist.
Gibt's Virtualbox Portable?
Ich glaube nicht, dass du irgendeine Virtualisierungslösung
installieren kannst unter Windows,
die nicht Admin-Rechte braucht.
Allein schon fürs Installieren von
irgendwelchen Netzwerk-Dreibern und sowas.
Doch, das neue
Windows-Terminal ist ganz okay.
Aber das ist ja natürlich da nicht drauf.
Oh, Sequin hör mal auf.
Das werde ich nie wieder benutzen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das wirkt alles sehr oldschool,
was sie da vorinstalliert haben.
Portable Virtualbox Instructions.
Ernsthaft? Das gibt's wirklich?
Ja, aber allein schon durch die Netzwerk-Dreiber
wird das doch nicht funktionieren.
Das ist ja nicht so richtig.
Durch die Netzwerk-Dreiber wird das doch nicht funktionieren.
Das ist auch wahrscheinlich nicht erlaubt,
denke ich mal.
Ne, es gibt so ein Portal,
worüber man was installieren kann,
aber da ist nichts dabei, was jetzt mein
Arbeiten unter Windows viel angenehmer macht.
Vielleicht Sprüchelstudio Code, aber das war's.
Hast du eigentlich dieses Jahr wieder
den ganzen Dezember frei?
Boah, das weiß ich noch nicht,
wie ich das mache.
Hängt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen davon ab,
wie die anderen
da Bock haben.
Also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
fanden es die Leute eigentlich recht nice,
weil es war immer,
das ganze Jahr über garantiert,
jemand am Start.
Die konnten im Sommer
und sonst wie immer Urlaub machen, wie sie wollten.
Dezember ist aber halt normalerweise
recht beliebt.
Ja,
mal gucken.
Das stellt sich dann schon auch raus.
Wie das ist.
Mit HotTube-Streams
wären es mehr Zuschauer.
Dass die Leute mich sehen wollen
in der Badewanne.
Es geht auch
mit dem offiziellen Image.
Tatsächlich.
Das kann
aber doch gar nicht funktionieren.
Du brauchst doch
einen Netzwerktreiber,
dass das klappt.
Und den kannst du nur installieren,
wenn du Admin-Rechte hast.
Dachte ich jetzt eigentlich.
Hattest du schon
HR-Onboarding-Stuff?
Das hatte ich im Vorfeld schon alles.
Ich bin ja eh
nicht der große Überstunden-Macher.
Ich gucke immer, dass ich
Plus Minus Null bin.
Und passt.
Ich bin ja eh nicht
der große Überstunden-Macher.
Ich gucke immer, dass ich
Plus Minus Null bin.
Und passt.
Hey Max, ist das,
was du auf der Arbeit machst, noch klassische
Physi-Arbeit?
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Gibt es klassische Physi-Arbeit
mittlerweile?
Ich meine,
das ist so breit gefächert.
Gerade was du als Physi später
machst.
Ich kenne sogar Leute, die haben
eine Physi-Ausbildung gemacht und programmieren jetzt.
Hauptberuflich.
Ich würde sagen,
es ist schon ein bisschen
weg
von dieser Standard-Geschichte,
wie man es beim Physi sich denkt.
Netzwerk-Config
und ein bisschen
Betriebssystem geklicke.
Client-Support mache ich selbstverständlich auch
keinen, würde ich im Leben irgendwo anfangen.
Client-Support ist wirklich das
allerletzte, was ich machen würde.
Ja, es ist schon nicht so das klassische Physi-Zeug,
wie es sich die IHK denkt.
Aber viele
Physis machen in ihrer Ausbildung auch nicht
das klassische Zeug, wie sich das die IHK
denkt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ne, ne, ne.
Du brauchst, du brauchst.
Ach so, ja, okay.
Das würde gehen.
Eine USB-Netzwerkkarte anschließen und die
durchreichen in die VM, ja, das würde
das würde wahrscheinlich
gehen.
Interessiert dich Entwicklung auch
wie Systemadministration?
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass mich
klassische Systemadministration
was ist, was mich groß
interessiert. Ich meine, ich bin
zwar Server-Admin in dem Sinn,
ja, das ist auch das, was ich quasi gelernt habe
beim Provider.
Aber es ist jetzt, ich kenne keinen,
der sagt, oh ja,
Systemadministration ist das, was mir super
viel Spaß macht.
Systemadministration ist meistens
relativ langweilig, langweiliges
Zeug.
Da legst du irgendwie einen User an,
checkst irgendwelche
Rechte auf irgendeinen Share
oder sowas. Das Drumherum ist
deutlich interessanter als Systemadministration
an sich. Aber du bist doch
öfters im Stream.
Du warst doch auch schon gesehen, dass wir
viele Programmier-Streams gemacht haben.
Ich meine, würde ich
Programmier-Streams machen, wenn mich Softwareentwicklung
nicht interessieren würde?
Oder
Chat, was meint ihr?
Das ist illegal, als Physi zu
programmieren.
Ja, kriegst du dann
Instant ist die Abmahnung
in der Post.
Hast du einen Tipp,
End-User-Support
oder was?
Naja, dich woanders
bewerben.
Weil,
wenn du im End-User,
wenn du quasi im Support bist, dann wirst du
ja logischerweise auch Support machen müssen.
Du kannst intern gucken.
Die meisten Arbeitgeber haben ja intern
auch so ein Jobportal.
Also die gucken ja intern erstmal, ob Leute
Bock haben, bevor sie sich da extern umgucken
und Bewerber suchen.
Da kannst du gucken. Ansonsten musst du
dich irgendwo anders bewerben.
Weil, wenn du jetzt
in irgendeinem Support-Team bist, ist das ja
so illusorisch
anzunehmen, man würde keinen Support machen.
Turnschuh-Administrator.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ja noch halbwegs interessant.
Wenn man ins Rechenzentrum geht und
im Rechenzentrum was einbaut und so.
Das ist aber nicht das, was ich unter Server-Administration
vielleicht auch, aber für mich ist
Server-Administration halt so super langweiliges
Zeug. Rechte vor nem Ordner
kontrollieren und sowas.
So das Einbauen, ich weiß nicht in welche
Kategorie das fällt, aber
das Einbauen von nem Server oder
das Wechsel von nem Lüfter
und sowas, das würde ich schon, das ist eher
Infrastruktur. Das würde ich jetzt
nicht so, das würde ich gar nicht so, auch wenn ich
das früher beim Provider den ganzen Tag gemacht hab,
so Dinger.
Da war ich ja mehrfach täglich im Rechenzentrum.
Das ist wirklich ne Sache,
die finde ich ein bisschen blöd,
dass ich so gar nicht mehr
ins Rechenzentrum muss.
Die letzten Male war ich
einfach nur just for fun, weil ich mal wieder Bock hatte
ins Rechenzentrum zu gehen drinnen, nicht weil ich musste.
Ich war ewig
nicht mehr im Rechenzentrum bei uns.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber und beim
neuen war ich noch gar nicht im Rechenzentrum,
weiß gar nicht, wo das ist.
Aber ich glaube, dass mein Alter
ein größeres eigenes Rechenzentrum hat
als der neue. Bin mir nicht sicher.
Keine Ahnung, war ja noch nicht drin.
Ja, so ab und zu mal
wieder ins Rechenzentrum, da hätte ich schon Bock drauf.
Nicht wirklich jetzt als
hauptberuflicher
Surfer auf
Wagen rumfahrer oder so, oder
auch nicht als Lüfter-Einbauer,
aber ab und zu mal im Rechenzentrum mal wieder
so ein Glasfaserkabel irgendwie bringen,
ein Patchpanel und
vielleicht mal wieder mit 1.2.9
ein Playcenter einbauen oder sowas.
Wobei ich glaube, kaum
jemand benutzt heute noch Playcenter.
Habt ihr noch Playcenter
auf der Arbeit, Chat?
Äh, wenn ich
weiß, was das ist. Ich meine sowas hier.
Sowas hier, meine ich.
Ne.
Ja, mein alter Arbeitgeber hat die
auch alle rausgeschmissen. Ob der neue welche hat,
weiß ich nicht.
Die waren cool, die Dinger.
Die muss man aber mit mehreren Leuten einbauen.
Die Dinger sind glaube ich
8 HE hoch, oder?
Ich glaube 8 HE.
Und extrem schwer.
Ich hab ja immer noch so einen Traum,
was ich gerne mal im Rechenzentrum machen würde.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich nie machen können,
aber
ich wollte schon immer mal gucken,
wenn man so einen Playcenter
auf leichtgängige Rollen schnallt,
so beispielsweise so einen Playcenter
auf Inlineskates oder so
schnallen
und dann ein Netzteil zieht,
sodass die Lüfter volle Pulle gehen,
oder irgendwas reinsteckt vorne,
dass die Lüfter volle Pulle gehen.
Ich wollte schon immer mal
wissen, wie schnell so ein Playcenter
werden kann bei Lüfter volle Pulle
auf leichtgängige Rollen.
Weil
ich weiß nicht,
ob es da Videos zu gibt, aber
die Dinger pusten dich,
also die pusten dich nicht um.
Das ist jetzt übertrieben, wenn ich sage,
die pusten dich um.
Aber die...
Wenn du dich hinter
so einen Playcenter
Ja.
Das ist aber falsch rum.
Der muss dahinter.
Ja.
Ne.
Ist das falsch rum?
Sind die anders rum jetzt?
Also
ich habe die Plates immer vorne rein
und raus gemacht.
Ja anscheinend
gibt's... Playcenter Booting!
Sehr gutes Video.
Flugzeug startet, Leute.
Formel 1 Auto.
Da brauchst du Hörschutz.
Naja, ich hatte...
Wir hatten im Rechenzentrum früher
immer Hörschutz
hängen, also so
Hörer am Eingang,
aber ich hab die Dinger nie aufgezogen.
Ja, das würde ich ausprobieren.
Also es war so, wenn du hinter so einem Playcenter
standest, wenn das
volle Pulle geblasen hat und wenn
das Ding der Meinung war, dass ein Netzteil
kaputt war,
dann hat es volle Pulle geblasen
und
Playcenter wurden gerne unten
in Racks eingebaut, weil die so groß und schwer
sind.
Und wenn man dann an das Playcenter musste
von hinten, dann hat man sich hinter das Playcenter
gekniet.
Oder nicht so gekniet, so in die Hocke ist man
hinter das Playcenter gegangen
und hat da dran rumgemacht. Und wenn das angegangen ist
und volle Pulle geblasen hat,
dann konntest du wirklich nur schwierig in der
Hocke hinter dem Playcenter sitzen, so sehr hat
es geblasen. Also es hatte schon
ordentlich Luftstrom, als da rausgekommen ist.
Ist jetzt keine
Flugzeugturbine,
aber ist schon ordentlich.
Aha.
Auf studieren hätte ich gar keinen Bock mehr.
Wobei jetzt
durch den Chat habe ich wenigstens den IQ
dafür.
Easy.
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen
einfach kollektiv studieren.
Twitch, Chat, Ghosts.
Twitch, Chat, Plays.
Informatik studieren.
Backseating.
Mädchen 2
Server im Ad... Moment.
Im Mädchen 2 Server kannst du doch
auf jeder
Smartwatch
heutzutage hosten.
Da brauchst du doch nichts für.
Die kenne ich nicht.
Ja.
Ah, die Bahn hatte heute Verspätung, Leute.
20 Minuten zu spät
heimgekommen, wegen dem Kackladen.
Ja.
Aua.
Men.
So sieht es aus.
Deswegen. Wir müssen mittlerweile richtig
massive High IQ haben. Soll ich mal kurz gucken
wie viele Subscriber
ich gerade habe.
Boah wenn es danach geht müsste ich glaube ich
der High IQ
igste
Mensch der Welt sein.
Wisst ihr was ich gemerkt habe?
Nick Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das bringt unglaublich viel wenn man
ich meine okay ihr werdet jetzt sagen Max
ist doch logisch ja hätte man auch selbst
drauf kommen können und ja ich meine es war mir auch klar
aber
ich habe jetzt ja die letzten Tage über relativ
regelmäßig gestreamt.
Nicht jetzt irgendwie teilweise 7-8 Stunden
wie das andere am Tag machen.
Richtig regelmäßig sogar
manchmal so an die 4 Stunden.
Das bringt das bringt schon was
was Subscriptions
und solche Dinge anbelangt.
Ja.
Ja war klar aber es
macht schon Unterschied ob man
zweimal die Woche
für 2-3 Stunden streamt
oder ob man quasi 3-4
Stunden fast jeden Tag streamt.
Am besten wäre natürlich
wenn man das wirklich auch zu
geregelten Zeiten
macht also dass die Leute wissen
dass stream ist
um so und so viel Uhr und sowas.
Oder ungefähr immer dann und dann.
Aber das kriege ich nicht auf die
Reihe. Es gibt auch Tage da habe ich
überhaupt keinen Bock.
Hättet ihr studieren was gebracht im Nachhinein
betrachtet. Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Weil ich ja nicht
weiß was ich dann gemacht hätte.
Es hätte ja durchaus meine
ein gesamter
Werdegang potenziell
anders verlaufen können.
Also wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht
ich hätte den absolut gleichen
Weg gemacht wie jetzt.
Dann würde ich sagen
hätten wir studieren. Naja was
heißt nix gebracht das kann man nicht sagen.
Ja ein bisschen theoretischen Background
bei manchen Sachen bei manchen
Dingen ist sicherlich
nie verkehrt.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
würde ich sagen eher nicht.
Ich habe Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration gelernt vor 15 Jahren.
Schon ein bisschen her.
Bei einem Internet Provider.
Aber keiner von den Großen.
Also wenn jetzt einer ankommt.
Ah ja Lulitelekom. Ne es war nicht die Telekom.
Studieren in Deutschland
bringt immer was.
Die Aussage stimmt aber nur
wenn du dir den Durchschnitt anguckst.
Also wenn du quasi vom Durchschnitt
darauf Schlussfolger hast, dass es immer was bringt
weil du ja im Durchschnitt theoretisch mehr verdienst.
Im Einzelfall muss das nicht so sein.
Also ich denke jetzt
ich gehe nicht davon aus
dass ich
bedeutend mehr
verdienen würde jetzt
wenn ich studiert hätte oder
krassere geilere Bedingungen hätte.
Warum geht denn
Dogecoin gerade so ab?
Aber
wegen dem Twitter Logo.
Oh man.
Ich meine
eigentlich ist das wie Geld drucken oder?
Die kaufen
Dogecoin, machen dann
das Twitter Logo zu einem
Dogecoin Ding und haben fett Kohle
damit verdient, weil jetzt der Kurs hoch geht.
Es war eigentlich fast schon wie Geld drucken
wenn die Twitter gehören.
Du hattest doch auch mal was
Sat-IP Zeugs bei dir laufen.
Also klassische Sat-IP
mit
Receiver im Keller
und
besser gesagt Tuner im Keller, Receiver
dann im Wohnzimmer und dann Sat-IP
dazwischen. Ne das habe ich nicht.
Ich benutze aktuell aber Sat-IP
allerdings lokal auf dem
Gerät. Also ich habe ja so
eine Box mit einem
8-fach Tuner. Ich habe
wie heißt dieses Ding?
Es ist möglich, dass es dieses
Teil ist. Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher
aus dem Kopf.
Ich halte es für
möglich, dass es dieses Teil ist.
Was ich habe?
Ne, ne, mein Teil
das sieht anders aus.
Uno, ich habe irgendwas mit Uno.
Irgendwas mit
Uno habe ich.
Ich glaube
das Teil habe ich, ja.
So und ich benutze das
halt nicht mit dem
Standard Zeug.
Meinst du ein Color Display?
Ich glaube nicht.
Doch kann schon sein. Also ich benutze
das Teil nicht Standard.
Das Standard Zeug ist
aus meiner Sicht nicht zu gebrauchen.
Da kommst du dir vor wie
mit einem Fernseher 1990.
Das Standard Zeug. Außerdem ist
die Serienaufnahmefunktion Schrott.
Das einzig Gute an dem Ding ist
dass es ein 8-fach Tuner hat
und ein Linux was du drauf laufen
lassen kannst.
Der Rest schockt nicht wirklich.
Ich würde es dafür nicht kaufen.
Auch die Kodi-Integration ist Müll.
Die Standard-Integration.
Ich habe jetzt die Kombination
laufen.
Ich habe
TV-Headend auf der Box drauf.
Mit dem Standard
Betriebssystem kannst du
eh vergessen. Auch mit diesem
Community Standard Betriebssystem kannst du
es vergessen. Man braucht Open
Open
Ich habe vergessen wie das
heißt.
OpenPTV
oder so.
OpenATV
Ja genau.
Das braucht man. Das ist ein halbwegs
neuer Kernel und neue Tools
und sowas. Da gibt es auch TV-Headend.
So was ich jetzt gemacht habe auf dem Ding.
Ich habe TV-Headend installiert.
Und damit
TV-Headend die Tuner gescheit
benutzen kann.
Weil die Tuner selbst mit TV-Headend
backen rum.
Oder funktionieren gar nicht.
Bin mir nicht sicher. Ich habe SATIP
drauf laufen. SATIP
für die 8-fach Tuner
und
TV-Headend erkennt direkt
die SATIP Tuner. Also ist quasi eine kleine
Zwischenschicht zwischen
TV-Headend und den Tunern.
Und dann habe ich auf meinem Shield-TV
im Wohnzimmer habe ich Kodi laufen
mit TV-Headend Plugin.
Das ist für mich, für Fernsehsachen
die beste Kombination
die ich bisher hatte.
Du hast ein komplett offenes System. Kannst machen was du willst.
Kriegst die Aufnahmen auch wieder raus.
Falls du die mal umziehen willst.
Hast mehr als genug Speicher mit einer ordentlichen Festplatte
drin. Ich habe sogar eine SSD glaub drin.
Ich glaube ich habe sogar eine SSD drin.
Ja.
Versucht aber nicht
mit dem Standardbetriebssystem
oder mit diesem Community Standard
mit dem Community Extensions
für das Standardbetriebssystem.
Das ist schon 2-3 Jahre her.
2 Jahre her.
Wo ich damit rumgebastelt habe.
Ich habe vergessen wie das Ding heißt.
Vielleicht weiß jemand von euch
wie das
wie das Standardbetriebssystem
heißt. Was die eigentlich alle
empfehlen. Was ich aber total
schrottig fand. Weil es
uralte
Linux-Keule
drauf hatte.
Also OpenATV ist es.
Und dann gibt es auch aktuelles TV-Headend
und sowas.
Das ist eine gute Kombi.
Das einzig Gute warum man die Kiste halt
verwenden kann ist weil es einen 8-fach Tuner drin hat.
Und eine schöne Box ist
mit einer internen Festplatte und einem Linux
drauf. Die Kombination ist gut.
Die Software die da mitgeliefert
wird und auch das wie das manche Leute
benutzen finde ich komplett schrottig.
Da kommst du dir vor wie auf so einer
Setupbox von 1995.
Ja aber
aber
OpenATV ist gut.
Mal die Repos gucken.
Gucken.
Ach keine Ahnung.
Das kann ich aber in der Kombination empfehlen.
Anderweitig nicht.
Easy.
Gar kein Problem.
Funktioniert.
Wir haben mal was ähnliches gemacht.
Wobei wir die Dinger nicht an hatten.
Wir hatten die Klamotten nicht an.
Wir haben mal
was ähnliches gemacht.
Allerdings war das bei uns im Büro.
Das war nicht im Rechenzentrum.
Wir hatten bei uns im Büro ein paar Switches
stehen.
So 3-4 Cisco-Switches.
Und die konnte man hier auch ordentlich
hochdrehen lassen.
Und da haben wir auch manchmal was dahinter getrocknet.
Das war aber so
zur Hälfte
weil es ganz praktisch ist
und zur anderen Hälfte
just for fun so.
Ist der Sebaru-Server down?
Wieso? Archive?
Nö geht doch alles.
Archive am Start.
Was? Woblos ist down? Wirklich?
Warum?
Ich hab die Domain
umgezogen.
Ich hab die Domain umgezogen.
War outdated und hat's
ausgemacht.
Dann leiten wir doch einfach
das kann ich nachher im DNS
machen. Dann leiten wir doch einfach
die normale Domain aufs Archiv
um oder?
Oder ist die bessere Variante als einfach ausschalten?
Kann ich nebenbei machen.
Ich kann meine VM mit
Ich mach das.
Ich mach das nebenbei.
Geht gleich wieder.
Ich log mich nebenbei ein
bei Cloudflare und
mach nen C-Record Eintrag.
Nicht C-Record.
C-Name.
Rekord Eintrag.
Nick Dankeschön für den Sub.
Deluxe.
Pogger Subscription.
Ne. Ne.
Kann man nicht so sagen.
Also wir haben bei uns
also früher
hier beim alten Arbeitgeber
hatten wir zwei Studierte die haben
im Support versauert.
Kann man nicht
sagen.
Das sich da für die groß gelohnt hätte.
Das haben sie bestimmt mitgekriegt.
Ich mach das mal kurz schnell hier.
Name Cheap.
Login.
Cons.
Äh.
Okay ich mach das.
Ich mach das doch nicht.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht
ich war hier schon eingeloggt.
Doch Name Cheap.
Bin ich doch.
Geht doch.
Keine Ahnung was das wieder für Schmerzen hat.
Verification Code.
Oh Shit man.
Okay Leute ich mach das nach am Stream.
Verification Code.
Ne.
Hat's ja vergessen.
So.
Ja es ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Ich denke mal
so ein bisschen theoretischer Hintergrund
bringt schon was.
Also ich hatte nach der Ausbildung
beim Provider 33.500
das weiß ich noch.
Was?
Was war das denn?
Was du vor einigen Jahren
auf dem Server mit der TV-Karte
hattest und was nutzt du da drauf?
Du meinst die alte
Kiste, du meinst dieses Ding?
Du meinst das mit der
TV wo ich die USB-TV-Karte
dran hatte? Das war so ein Teil
hier.
Mit
hier. Das war ja quasi so
eine externe Festplatte
mit Microcontroller.
Da habe ich das
offizielle Betriebssystem glaube ich von denen
drauf gehabt. Ne das stimmt nicht.
Da haben wir Arch Linux drauf gemacht.
Lul.
Wir haben Arch Linux drauf gemacht.
Das weiß ich noch. Wir haben nämlich Arch Linux drauf gemacht
weil
die
Passwort
nein ich habe
mein Passwort nicht vergessen.
Wir haben Arch Linux
drauf gemacht
weil der
Kernel zu alt war
von dem
mitgelieferten OS
und deswegen haben wir Arch Linux
drauf gemacht und einen eigenen
Kernel kompiliert.
Das weiß ich noch.
Und dann
lief das halbwegs.
Ich mache das
übrigens jetzt doch nebenbei
Leute mit der
mit der Domain.
Ich muss mich jetzt nur mal zwei Faktor mäßig
anmelden auf der anderen Seite.
Das ist gerade wieder richtig
zu secure
alles.
Da kann man nämlich
die Domain jetzt gleich fixen.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Submit.
So.
Also.
Wir haben jetzt
die
So. Also.
Was
braucht man denn das es funktioniert?
Archive.wobloss geht.
Wobloss.tv
geht nicht.
Also brauche ich ein CNAME
für Wobloss.tv.
Mache das mal schnell.
Manage DNS.
So.
Normales
Update.
CNAME
archive
wobloss.tv
So.
Jetzt schauen wir mal ob es funktioniert.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Die Namensauflösung dürfte
ein bisschen dauern.
Aber
demnächst sollte das wieder
funktionieren.
Sollte gleich
wieder tun.
Schauen wir gleich mal.
Können wir mal eine Viertelstunde
gucken.
Wie es dann aussieht.
Hast du HD Plus?
Ne habe ich nicht.
Habe ich auch nicht eingesehen
mir das zu kaufen. Ganz ehrlich.
Das ist der einzige Vorteil
der öffentlich rechtlichen Sender.
Dass es HD
quasi umsonst gibt.
Ich meine die kriegen auch genug Geld.
Wie viel hatten die letztes Jahr?
77 Milliarden oder sowas.
Heftig was da für Geld
verblasen wird.
Welches Tool hattest du zum Verschlüsseln
der Festplatte genommen?
Also unter Windows.
Wohlgemerkt.
Unter Linux natürlich
nicht. Wobei du
unter Linux mittlerweile
Seracrypt Volumes
out of the box mounten kannst.
Falls du mal
Rescue Disk dran musst.
Meine Eltern
wollen einfach nur Problemlos aufnehmen und viel Speicher
halt normal typauschauen. Geht das damit?
Das ist schon die Kombination
die ich habe. Ein bisschen was für Technik
versierte Leute. Sollte mal
irgendwas nicht funktionieren
was sehr selten vorkommt. Aber durchaus
schon mal sein kann.
Einmal im Jahr oder so.
Einmal im Jahr ist
mal irgendwas und die Kiste muss vielleicht mal neu gestartet
werden.
Könnte es schwierig werden.
Je nachdem wie gut du die eingerichtet hast.
Ob deine Eltern damit klarkommen oder nicht.
Bei mir ist es einfach. Ich starte die Kiste neu.
Logge mich per SSH ein.
Starte mein
Innenskript quasi.
Und dann geht
wieder alles.
Schalte die mitgelieferte Oberfläche aus.
Schaltet
SatIP ein. TV Headend ein.
Und fertig.
Serious Max. Ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob das geht.
Ist das ein Zertifikat
was nur für Archive ausgestellt ist?
Dann geht das ja nicht.
Wupp.
Nee geht immer noch nicht.
Ich glaube das ist jetzt
ein DNS Cache der rumspackt.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal in der VM was passiert.
Ich habe mehr YouTube Tabs
offen als du.
Ja ich habe viele Tabs offen.
Ich meine irgendwo muss ich ja mit meinen
64GB RAM hin.
Diesen Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Bei was?
Wie?
Was muss man dafür installieren?
Bind?
Nicht wirklich.
Oder?
Moin Chainlore.
Auch mal wieder am Start.
Bind?
Aber warum?
Bind ist doch...
Ich will doch kein Bind
installieren.
Was ist denn das hier schon wieder für ein Kackmann?
Der erste Tag war ganz okay.
Was Drill? Drill habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Wir können auch Pacman
SQ?
Ist es?
Oder nur Q?
Oh man.
Ich kann mir das
immer noch nicht merken.
Pacman minus F?
Okay.
Was ist Epic 4?
IRC Development?
Monk IS?
Alter was?
Aber Bind
Tools gibt es doch gar nicht.
Gibt keine
Bind Tools.
Es gibt nur Bind.
Installieren wir halt Bind.
Ich muss ihn ja nicht starten.
woblords.tv
Das ist aber nicht richtig.
Dass da ein A-Record zurückkommt.
Da sollte eigentlich
ein C-Name
kommen.
Wollen wir schon mal hier gucken.
Das geht ja gegen meinen Cache, du hast recht.
Das ist richtig so.
Das ist gut so.
Mein Router hat wahrscheinlich
gecached.
Das ist richtig so.
Das sieht okay aus.
C-Name auf dem Root.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es anders machen soll.
Weil
das Zertifikat ist glaube ich nur für Archive.
Sollte jetzt funktionieren.
Mehr als kaputt gehen kann es nicht.
Hattest du nicht
in deiner 3-4-5
Moment, das war eine 2-HE-Kiste.
Nee.
Eine 4-HE-Kiste
war das glaube ich.
Eine 4-HE-Kiste.
3 oder 4, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich glaube eine 4-HE-Kiste.
3 ist so untypisch.
Einfach die IP als A-Record.
Ja, das bringt dir aber nichts, wenn das Zertifikat
nur für das Archiv ausgestellt ist.
Ist das
ein Wildcard-Zertifikat?
Ansonsten bringt
das nichts, wenn ich die IP eintrage.
Ach, das ist ein Wildcard-Zertifikat.
Dann ist es easy.
Dann kann ich auch
die IP
nehmen.
Sag doch gleich, dass es
ein Wildcard-Zertifikat ist.
Löschen.
Add.
Dann ist es easy.
Wusste ich nicht, dass es ein Wildcard-Zertifikat ist.
So.
Jetzt.
Gucken wir mal.
IP-Leak.
OMG.
Jetzt dauert es noch ein bisschen,
bis er es gecheckt hat.
Gnome?
Ich weiß nicht, wie du auf Gnome kommst.
Also ja, ich hatte eine 4-HE-Kiste.
Da war eine TV-Karte.
Da war so eine
Win-Dings-Tuner.
Win-Tune.
Ja.
Karte, Dual-Tuner-Karte
drin. Ja, doch.
Hatte ich, ja.
Die Kiste habe ich auch noch, aber
die habe ich nicht mehr im Einsatz, weil die einfach nur
oversized als Farqua
und vor allem unsinnig Strom
gefressen hat.
Und mittlerweile eigentlich auch schon veraltet ist.
Habe gerade ein Archealux mit einem
Gnome-Desktop installiert. Normalerweise hat man
doch beim Einloggen die Möglichkeit,
den Display-Server auszuwählen.
Wayland vs. Xorg, die Option gibt es bei mir
nicht. Weiß ich nicht,
was man da für Packages unter Arch installieren
muss. Oder ob
es da irgendwelche Meta-Packages für gibt.
Weil
ich kann Wayland in der VM nicht gescheit benutzen.
Deswegen
ist es X
und bleibt wahrscheinlich auch X.
Ja,
lokaler Cache
ist noch drin.
Das bringt nichts.
Ich müsste es auf meinem Router löschen.
Was,
Natel ist Schweizerdeutsch für Handy?
Natel?
Ja,
also ich habe immer noch ein iPhone.
Ich habe aktuell ein iPhone 14.
Ich habe mir sogar letztens ein
iPad Pro gekauft.
Richtig unsinnige Geldverschwendung,
aber hat was.
Richtig,
das zeige ich euch mal.
Das ist natürlich
Richtig,
das ist zwar ein bisschen schwerer, aber größer und
ein nices Display und so.
Also,
ja, was das angeht.
Ich habe jetzt
zwei Handys. Ich habe vom neuen Arbeitgeber
jetzt auch eins. Ein iPhone
12, glaube ich, ist das.
Und ich habe mein iPhone
14.
Ich habe aber auch Android-Geräte
hier. Ich bin der Meinung, es macht
überhaupt keinen Sinn, sich darüber zu streiten,
ob jetzt Android besser ist oder
iOS oder
Android oder Apple oder was auch immer.
Also erstens soll jeder benutzen, was ihm am besten liegt
und zweitens haben alle
beide Systeme, wahrscheinlich
hätte sogar Windows-System
seine Vorteile.
Windows Mobile,
wie hieß das Ding? Seine Vorteile
gehabt, wobei das war schon echt
schrottig, ja. Windows Phone,
genau. Aber
es haben beide Systeme Vorteile,
nämlich zum Beispiel,
dass alles, was
um Automatisierung geht
unter Android einfach um Längen
besser ist,
als was du
jemals wahrscheinlich mit iOS
machen kannst. Das liegt aber
auch ein bisschen so an der Philosophie
dahinter.
Apple
mag halt manche Sachen nicht
und wenn Apple Sachen nicht mag, dann kannst
du in der Regel davon ausgehen, dass die auch nicht gehen.
Unter Android mögen
manche Sachen standardmäßig nicht gehen, aber du
kannst es meistens trotzdem irgendwie machen.
Also was du zum Beispiel bei Android
easy machen kannst, ist
ein Background-Job
einrichten, der alle
15 Sekunden
irgendeinen Server queriert oder so.
Kannst du mit Tasker machen,
kannst du mit irgendeinem Shell-Skript machen, wenn
du da eine Umgebung hast, das geht.
Unter
iOS funktioniert das nicht gescheit,
weil
die Sachen werden nach spätestens, wenn du
irgendeine Schleife startest, beispielsweise
in Workflows oder so,
dann
wird das nach
glaube ich spätestens 10 Sekunden beendet.
Hast du ein Custom-Room auf deinen
Android-Handys? Ich habe keine Android-Handys,
ich habe Android-Tablets
und die haben Custom-Rooms. Ich habe
zwei Fire HD10
hängen hier an der Wand
als Dashboard für meine Heimautomatisierung
und die anderen Sachen
habe ich alle nicht mehr in Verwendung.
Auf meinem Shield-Tablet habe ich
in irgendeinem Lineage-OS
aber das benutze ich gar nicht mehr,
das Shield-Tablet.
Ich habe eigentlich
nur noch die zwei
Fire HD10 im Einsatz
mit Android, die geflasht sind.
Den Rest
benutze ich nicht mehr.
Also
die Hardware, die ich bekommen habe auf der Arbeit
ist wirklich nice. Das ist, glaube ich,
irgendein i7-Notebook mit 32G-RAM.
Was
KalixOS ist, das kenne ich nicht.
Auch irgendein Android
Ja,
es ist ein Android.
Device-Support, ja, nur Pixels.
Da habe ich nichts von.
Hast du
freie OS-Auswahl?
Ne.
Habe ich nicht.
Zumindest habe ich noch nicht
genervt deswegen. Aktuell haben sie
mir ein Windows-Notebook ohne irgendwelche Tools
hingeknallt.
Aber hey, ich werde
schon mal gucken, wie man das auf die Reihe kriegt
und im Zweifelsfall auch nerven.
Was ist eigentlich
der Nachteil von einem
Wildcard-Zertifikat?
Der einzige Nachteil,
der mir da jetzt so spontan
auf die Reihe kommt,
ist, dass
es
nicht so einfach ist,
um das wildcard-Zertifikat
zu benutzen.
Also
ich habe
zwei Nachteile,
zwei Nachteile
fallen mir spontan ein.
Der erste ist allerdings
nicht so wild.
Du kannst es halt nicht wirklich gut kontrollieren,
welches Zertifikat für was verwendet wird,
weil du eins für alles verwendest.
Und wenn du verschiedene Subdomains hast,
wo verschiedene Leute für zuständig sind
oder verschiedene Teams für zuständig sind,
ja, ist das vielleicht eher wünschenswert,
dass das nicht selbst ausgestellt wird.
Aber das viel entscheidendere ist,
dass du mit Wildcard-Zertifikaten
schneller,
wenn du nicht aufpasst,
in Let's Encrypt Limits läufst,
als mit einzelnen Zertifikaten.
Weil du kannst so ein Wildcard-Zertifikat
glaube ich nur fünfmal oder siebenmal,
ich glaube fünfmal, oder?
Nur fünfmal
alle
14 Tage,
ich weiß die Limits aus dem Kopf nicht,
renewen.
Das ist nicht schlimm normalerweise, weil die laufen
mehrere Monate, aber wenn du
Sachen testest,
dann willst du das vielleicht
doch mal öfters machen
und nicht jedes Mal auf
Staging umschalten.
Also mit
Wildcard-Zertifikaten läufst du viel schneller
in
Let's Encrypt Limits als mit
einzelnen Zertifikaten.
Es gibt aber einen Trick,
wenn man in
Let's Encrypt Limits gelaufen ist,
einfach noch
eine zweite Domain mit anfordern,
in dem
Request, weil Let's Encrypt
limitiert die Requests
und nicht die
einzelnen Domains. Also wenn du ein
Zertifikat anforderst für
keckel.lul.de
und du forderst gleichzeitig
keckelkeckw.lul.de
und dann ist das ein neuer
Request. Das geht,
ja.
Dementsprechend
kannst du auch Wildcard-Zertifikate und
Subdomain-Zertifikate
zusammen anfordern und sowas
und dann kann man die Limits ein bisschen
austricksen. Das funktioniert.
Also du hast verpasst, nö.
Wir machen heute auch nichts Großartiges.
Kann man ein
Wildcard-Zertifikat
automatisch beantragen? Ja.
Das ist ja der Sinn von Let's Encrypt.
Dass er so weit wie möglich automatisch funktioniert.
Hyper-V
habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Welche
Tastatur benutzt du
beziehungsweise welche kannst du empfehlen?
Also ich habe auf der einen
Seite
den
Zertifikat
und auf der anderen Seite
den
Wildcard-Zertifikat.
Und die
Zertifikate sind
automatisch
verwendet.
Welche kannst du empfehlen?
Auf der Arbeit habe ich
eine Duckyborn Skyline. Die liegt da jetzt
im Schrank. Die habe ich heute mit hingenommen.
Und eine Logitech G502.
Und hier daheim habe ich eine Logitech-Tastatur.
Da weiß ich aus dem Kopf auch gerade gar nicht
welche das ist.
Die würde ich jetzt nicht so unbedingt empfehlen.
Aber die ist okay.
Das ist in Ordnung. Das ist jetzt keine Tastatur
mit der mich voll in Verzückung versetzt.
Aber die ist in Ordnung.
Was habe ich denn für eine Tastatur?
Mal kurz gucken.
G512.
Mit so einer Handball-Auflage.
Kann man eigentlich sein Apple-iPhone auf Viren
überprüfen?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es irgendwelche
Antiviren-Software
für iPhones gibt.
Allein schon, weil
es sich wahrscheinlich gut verkaufen lässt
bei manchen Leuten.
Ob die sinnvoll funktionieren und
ob die gut was erkennen.
Keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich mich bisher nicht mit beschäftigt.
Ich glaube so einfach ist das
bei mir nicht.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich glaube du kriegst
ein Zertifikat
mit zwei Namen drin.
Keine Ducky für Zuhause?
Ne, ich will die auch daheim nicht verwenden.
Was mir bei der Ducky One Skyline fehlt
ist, dass du
eine gescheite Software hast.
Was unter Windows sehr praktisch ist,
gerade wenn man für Games was ummappen will
oder deine Makros
braucht, die halt auch so aussehen, als
kommen sie wirklich aus der Tastatur und nicht
kommen sie aus irgendeinem
Auto-Hotkey
oder so.
Das geht mit der Ducky nur
sehr beschränkt, was Makros angeht.
Für daheim ist die nix.
Und ich glaube für das Gaming
wird die mir auch nicht gut gefallen.
Ja, die klicken ziemlich.
Die klicken ziemlich,
die Tastatur.
Fehlt dir da nicht der Numblock?
Ich habe einen Numblock.
Alle meine Tastaturen
haben einen Numblock.
Ich finde nicht sinnvoll
auf einen Numblock zu verzichten.
Wie ist das bei euch Leute?
Habt ihr noch einen Numblock?
Einige Kollegen, von denen weiß ich,
die mögen gerne
so Mini-Tastaturen.
Da gibt es teilweise
auch Tastaturen,
die haben gar keine...
Die haben nicht mal diesen Block mit den
Pfeiltasten und sowas.
Die haben quasi nur dieses normale Keyboard-Feld
und sonst nichts.
Das ist dann halt ein Drittel kleiner,
die Tastatur.
60%?
Ja, okay.
Ich mag das nicht.
Ich habe am liebsten
so eine richtig fette Tastatur.
Beprophet.
...
Ich gucke mir gleich noch